hey Luke here with the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and I do a lot of
extreme cold weather camping in some
awful conditions I've taken my wife and
three kids into some really extreme
weather and because of that I've got 24
tips I think can help anyone stay warm
all right this first tip will keep you
crazy warm take your summer hydration
bladder fill it full of hot water and
wear it under your winter clothes a
small 2-liter hydration bladder will
keep you warm for well over eight hours
for the ultimate luxury fill your
hydration bladder with your favorite hot
drink and you'll be smiling all day long
just make sure to wash it out when
you're done otherwise it'll grow mold
number two on my list adhesive body
warmers I always keep a few in the car
and in my first aid kits these body
warmers are just large hand warmers with
an adhesive sticker on the back that
allows you to stick them directly to
your body you don't want to stick it
directly to your skin because they get
too hot so make sure to put it on your
base layer after you open the package it
takes about 45 minutes for the body
warmer to start giving off heat but then
they'll last for over 12 hours I'm a
firm believer that there's no situation
too cold if you have enough adhesive
body warmers sometimes in real extreme
weather I like to stick an adhesive body
warmer to the back of my cell phone to
keep the battery from die and the
company that makes adhesive body warmers
they also make hand warmers adhesive toe
warmers heated inserts for your shoes
and an enormous laugh warmer if your
gear isn't quite good enough to keep you
warm buy a packet of adhesive body
warmers and it'll get the job done next
on my list hot water bottles whether
you're at home or out in the woods a hot
water bottle can go a long way to
warming you up hot water bottles come in
all shapes and sizes and you can even
buy them with a thing called a cozy a
cozy is just a fuzzy sleeve that keeps
the hot water bottle from burning your
skin and keeps the heat in longer hot
water bottles are great for preheating
your sleeping bag keeping you warm
throughout the night or just having
something to cuddle up with when you're
sitting next to the fire if you don't
have a dedicated hot water bottle you
can fill up a Nalgene bottle with hot
water and put it in your sleeping bag or
under your coat just make sure to check
it for leaks before putting it in your
sleeping bag if you wake up in the
morning to Frozen boots two water
bottles can work great for thawing your
boots out if you have big feet you can
use two nalgen bottles full of hot water
if you have little feet you can use two
Gatorade bottles if your feet get cold
easily make sure you own a pair of down
camping slippers they weigh next to
nothing take up no space in your bag and
they'll keep your feet extremely warm
down camping slippers are great for
wearing around inside the tent or
trailer and you can even wear them in
your sleeping bag at night I prefer the
Western mountaineering brand camping
slippers because they have just enough
sole on them that I can go outside the
tent if I need to use the bathroom or
sneak outside to grab something if your
feet get cold easily make sure you're
always wearing a pair of dry socks
especially when you go to bed when we
start to sweat the first things to get
wet is usually our feet our feet are wet
so often we often don't notice how wet
they are before you go to bed change
into dry socks if your feet start to get
cold stop and change into dry socks and
if you don't have a pair of dry socks
take the time to air out your feet and
dry your socks by the fire before
putting them on and going to bed if you
don't have the opportunity to get dry
socks on before you go to bed pull your
socks off and put them in the foot of
your sleeping bag before you go to sleep
it's better to go to sleep with no socks
on rather than wet socks plus when you
wake up in the morning the heat of your
bag will have dried your socks off make
sure you get a good sleeping mat your
sleeping mat is more important for
keeping you warm than your sleeping bag
sleeping bags don't insulate very well
when their insulation is compressed so
the part of your sleeping bag in between
you and the ground doesn't do much to
keep you warm additionally touching Cold
Ground will cool your body two to four
times faster than touching cold air so
the mat you sleep on is way more
important for keeping you warm than your
sleeping bag the measure of a good
sleeping mat is its R value the higher
the better at zero degrees you want an R
value about six and at negative 20 you
want an R value of seven or eight if
your mat doesn't have a good enough R
value you can stack multiple thinner
mats on top of each other in order to
stay warm sometimes I'll take layers of
cardboard and put it under my mat to
increase the R value of my sleep system
make sure your mats also big enough and
wide enough for you especially if you
tend to roll around a lot at night if
you roll off your mat in the middle of
the night you're going to wake up really
cold getting the right sleeping bag is
very important if you want to stay warm
while camping size your sleeping bag
correctly you want your sleeping bag to
be as small as possible without it
restricting any of your movements make
sure to test out your sleeping bag in
all the different sleeping positions you
might find yourself in if there is
tightness the insulation will be
compressed and you'll have a cold spot
in that location a bag that is too big
will also be colder because it has more
surface area for heat to escape through
if you have a sleeping bag that is too
long you can either stuff clothes in the
foot of the bag or you can roll up and
clamp the foot of the sleeping bag to
reduce the Dead Space and when you buy
sleeping bags don't believe the
temperature ratings sleeping bag ratings
are very loosey-goosey for normal people
you want your bag rating to be 20
degrees Fahrenheit lower than the
expected low temperature when you're
camping but if you get cold easily your
minimum temperature might be as much as
40 to 60 degrees above whatever that
says on the sleeping bag when I take my
wife out camping I typically have a bag
that's rated for 60 degrees Fahrenheit
colder than whatever we expect to
experience if you don't have a sleeping
bag with a good enough rating system
don't be afraid to stuff a second
sleeping bag inside your sleeping bag if
you want your gear to keep you warm
you've got to store it correctly make
sure your sleeping bags down jackets
puffy pants down booties all of those
need to be stored either hung up or in a
storage sack do not store them
compressed their insulation will get
flattened and compressed and then it
won't work very well this is especially
true for anything made with real down I
try not to leave my sleeping bag in the
compression sack for more than two to
three days at a time pound for pound one
of the best articles of clothing to keep
you warm is a balaclava they're also
great for keeping your head warm when
sleeping especially if you don't like
the feeling of a mummy bag Hood over
your head while you sleep they can be
worn as a neck gaiter and they are also
good for keeping the sun off your face
on a sunny day out on the ice if you're
going to be doing strange newest
physical activity out in the cold it's
really important to have proper layers
layers allow you to adjust your body
temperature and to manage sweat so that
you don't get wet if you do get wet once
you stop exerting yourself you'll cool
down and get extremely cold generally
speaking you want base layers mid layers
and an outer shell the base layer goes
against your skin and helps Wick away
sweat away from your skin your mid layer
should have the most insulation of all
your layers a good outer shell protects
you from wind and water but also allows
sweat and Vapor to escape Gore-Tex is
one of the best materials for doing this
but you also want an outer layer with
vents typically these vents are in the
crotch and in the armpits by unzipping
your vents you allow a lot of heat and
moisture to escape without exposing your
mid layer to outside moisture if for
whatever reason you find yourself
getting really sweaty while being
Physically Active out in the cold dry
yourself out before you stop your
activity so that you don't get really
cold if you have small kids keeping
their hands warm is a constant battle
kids don't like wearing gloves and
mittens they take them off constantly
and they can't get them back on
themselves instead of giving kids gloves
buy them nice winter jackets with longer
sleeves that go all the way to the tips
of their fingers the kids can pull their
fingers in and out of the sleeves
without your help and they often prefer
this over wearing gloves unless the kids
need to be touching the snow and ice
with their hands this is a great
solution even in pretty cold condition
when you stand next to a campfire only a
small percentage of the heat is directed
towards you a heat reflector will
increase that percentage very noticeably
a heat reflector can be any hard surface
that absorbs and reflects heat a heat
reflector can be made from logs or it
can be something natural like a large
rock or a fallen log a heat reflector
can also block the wind and keep the
smoke from blowing into your face if I'm
going to spend a lot of time warming
Myself by a fire I usually make a heat
reflector often the coldest part of my
winter trips is when I get out of the
car so before you arrive at your
destination turn down the heater so
you're just a little bit chillier at
least cool your body will switch from
trying to cool itself down to trying to
warm itself up and it's not as much of a
shock when you get out of the car not
eating or drinking enough can make you
bitterly cold your body needs energy to
produce heat and when you get thirsty or
your blood sugar gets low you get tired
and stop moving around as much which
also makes you cold little kids are
especially bad at recognizing when they
are hungry or thirsty when they're out
and about or having a good time when
you're out in the cold proactively eat
and drink before you get cold or hungry
or thirsty this will help keep you
warmer longer more is not better when it
comes to wearing socks rather than
having big fuzzy socks it's more
important to have moisture wicking socks
that are comfortable and don't restrict
any blood flow reduce circulation and
wet feet are the biggest enemies of
keeping your feet warm kneeling sitting
or even standing on ice for long periods
of time will get you very cold if you
know you're going to be stationary for a
while make sure there's something in
between you and The Frozen Ground if you
don't have a camping chair use a pile of
Pine bow or use your sleeping bag or a
sleeping mat or even your backpack just
have something in between you and the
ground also when you sit next to a fire
if you sit in an angle to the fire with
your side closest to the fire rather
than your feet you'll get a lot more
heat from the fire the worst part of
winter camping is getting out of a warm
sleeping bag and putting on cold clothes
store your clothes in the foot of your
sleeping bag so that they are warm when
you put them on the next morning this
can also help get rid of dead space in
your sleeping bag if your bag is a bit
big for you or if your clothes are a
little bit damp this can also help dry
them out before the morning try to pick
a thawed dry spot to set up your
sleeping area if you can't find a thawed
dry area build a big fire then move the
fire over and set up your sleeping area
on the thawed dry ground where the fire
used to be I've used this trick to stay
warm while sleeping on the ground
without a tent sleeping bag or mat
stringing up a tarp as a Windbreak can
make a big difference if there's any
wind at all whether you're sleeping in a
tent or standing around the fire having
that Windbreak can make a big difference
in keeping you warm the ultimate
solution to staying warm while winter
camping is a hot tet these tents are
specifically designed to be heated with
propane or wood stoves however even if
your stove is roaring hot inside the
floor of the tent will usually still be
very cold there can be as much as a 90
degree Fahrenheit difference between the
temperature at the ceiling versus the
floor there's two solutions for this
problem either one get a battery powered
ceiling fan to help circulate the air or
two use cots sleeping a few inches or a
few feet off the ground can make a huge
difference in temperature when you're in
a hot tent if you want to use a heater
inside a tent I highly recommend the Mr
Heater brand heater there's the little
buddy and the Big Buddy heaters while
there's always risks associated with
using a heater in a tent these heaters
are specifically designed to be used
inside they have oxygen depletion shut
off switches tip switches and the
heaters are safe to touch everywhere but
the grill well sometimes you just need
the warmest gear no matter what so
here's a list of the enormous gear money
can buy first on the list is the Arctic
oven Igloo hot tent I have owned one of
these for several years and I tested it
at negative 60 degrees Fahrenheit it was
so warm that we had to open the windows
and turn down the stove because it was
too hot at negative 60. another thing
unusual about this tent is it's actually
manufactured here in Alaska The
Feathered friend snowy owl is rated to
negative 60 degrees Fahrenheit and is
the warmest sleeping bag in the world
Feathered Friends is a brand that's well
known among hardcore Mountaineers and
hikers for their high quality down
sleeping bags and clothing one thing
Feathered Friends is known for is having
more truthful ratings on their sleeping
bags if a Feathered Friends bag says
zero degrees Fahrenheit it's going to be
a lot warmer than other cheaper zero
degree bags on the market Feathered
Friends will customize the length of any
of their bags for you I had them
customize the length of several of their
bags for my children so they can have
high quality sleeping bags in cold
weather camping situations the biggest
problem with the Feathered Friends snowy
owl is that it's way too warm for most
camping situations for normal people if
you're in weather above negative 20
there's a good chance you're going to be
too warm unless you're my wife she likes
to use it anytime the weather gets below
40 degrees fahrenheit as far as I've
been able to discover the warmest
sleeping man on the market is the exped
R8 sleeping mat it's rated to negative
40 degrees it comes in a variety of
lengths and widths the remarkable thing
about the R8 sleeping mat is it's not
that expensive and it's extremely
compact Baffin Boots makes the warmest
boots on Earth particularly warm are
their impact model
and the guide Pro 2. while boot ratings
are not exact the Baffin impact is rated
to negative 148 degrees Fahrenheit what
makes Baffin Boots one of my favorite
brands on this list is that they make
extreme cold weather boots for just
about everyone the Baffin snow goose is
rated to negative 60 and it comes in
kids sizes in both boy and girl models
additionally Baffin Boots cost only
slightly more money than other name
brand boots warmest thing you can wear
in your hands is the Outdoor Research
altitude Gore-Tex insulated mittens I
bought a pair of these 28 years ago and
I still use them today however the older
models have this synthetic rubber Palm
that feels like a truck bed liner and
it's indestructible newer models have
this soft supple leather on the palm and
it will not last nearly as long here you
can see a pair of gloves I bought last
Christmas that have the same leather
Palm as the new or altitudes and it's
almost destroyed so if you're going to
buy a pair of these or gloves look for
the older models with the synthetic
rubber Palm the only thing that comes
even close to being as warm as the or
ulti 2 is a pair of handmade double
layered beaver skin mittens for keeping
your legs warm nothing beats the Western
mountaineering flight pants these pants
are crazy warm and luxurious the biggest
problem is that they're so puffy that
you'll have a hard time fitting them
under normal snow pants they weigh
almost nothing in compact super small so
I keep them in my bag and use them for
wearing around the tent or in my
sleeping bag the warmest hoodie in the
world is made by a company called
refrigerator it's the polar Force
sweatshirt and it's rated to negative 40
degrees Fahrenheit I've taken mine at
negative 50 degrees and I was just fine
refrigerator is a company that's known
for making extreme cold weather clothing
that's more durable particularly if
you're in the construction industry
you're going to be working outside in
extreme weather this is what you want
when it comes to the warmest jacket in
the world there's no one clear winner
there are several jackets that stand out
from the rest if you want a
mountaineering style jacket the Mountain
Hardwear absolute zero jacket is hard to
beat they also make a full body down own
suit version that's thirteen hundred
dollars if you're looking for more of a
parca style jacket the Canada Goose Snow
Mantra parka is generally considered the
best of the best and it's also about
thirteen hundred dollars Canada Goose
also makes what is arguably the warmest
kid jacket in the world the youth
Expedition parka PBI that runs a
thousand dollars I got this jacket for
my five-year-old son Nathan when we were
gonna go on an expedition to Greenland
that was canceled because of covid and
while I do believe it is the warmest
kids jacket in the world it's only
marginally warmer than the next best
thing while Canada goose is a brand that
has its roots in Antarctic expedition
and cold weather gear they are
transitioning into becoming a high-end
fashion brand most of their gear now is
about being seen rather than being warm
if you want an Extreme Performance parka
without the fashion brand name the kovic
brand is hard to beat kovic is the
retail brand of Big Ray's retail store
in Alaska and the kovic brand premiered
down parka is very comparable to the
Canada Goose Snow Mantra but almost a
thousand dollars cheaper this is the
parka me my wife and my oldest son Tommy
have been using for the last few years
and this parka will easily go down to
negative 80 or worse well hopefully you
learned something if you want to see me
actually use these tips and go on some
pretty crazy Outdoor Adventures make
sure to click subscribe to the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel we put out new
videos every Saturday morning all right
guys I'll see you then if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
and you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]